[Music]
[Music]
the greatest showmen scaleless settle
belts this is me at the 2018 oscars ET
was with her last month ahead of the
powerful performance I got a text saying
by the way have you had your true like
pinch me moment yet oh no because so
much of this has been happening and then
it's incredible it's so incredible and
it keeps going and it keeps going and I
do have to take those moments where I
not only try to pinch myself but just
breathe and remember how I got here and
why I'm here if I even know what that
means and just kind of accept all the
good it's like not only is the movie
great the soundtrack straight it's also
been at the top of the charts for weeks
and weeks and weeks what does that mean
to you it means a lot it means it means
that we really do need some kind of hope
right now not just nationally but
universally and to be able to facilitate
that is a it's a very very very huge
honor just to be a part of it this is
resident I'm asking everybody tonight if
they have received a piece of advice
maybe early on maybe recently that
really stuck with you is there any piece
of advice that you got maybe working on
this film I did actually recently do a
job with a friend of mine Melissa
McCarthy he was now a friend of mine I
can say that and she's done and the last
when we rapped on the job that we did
she took my hands and she said I know
that you're scared and I know that
you're stressed out right now but she
said don't forget to stop and breathe
and take it all in because you will
never get these first-time moments ever
again and I am sticking to my guns on
that take it all and especially the